all right Leslie Leslie where'd you grow
up for you from Baltimore Maryland Shum
City okay and tell me about your family
you hit both your parents growing up no
I never met my father until later on but
in fact about six years ago I actually
met him but my mom's was my primary
caretaker I have two younger brothers
one of them now deceased and youngest
brother my brother Craig is a he retired
he was a correctional officer for the
Department of Public Safety and
Correctional Services and Baltimore and
tell me buddy chocolate yeah
good children y'all had a pretty good
childhood I mean I spent a lot of my
time traveling back and forth I actually
was raised by my godmother in Brooklyn
New York and I would be sent to back to
my mom's house to spend time in the
summer there and Baltimore well worried
not with your mom full-time huh why were
you not with your mom full-time ah to be
honest which I really believe it was
because of her animosity and and sincere
attitude with my father you know whom I
never met you know I I bared the burden
of being his child okay and then tell me
what kind of kid were you in high school
high school I was pretty good as far as
the student and I was real good with
working stuff I did my book and got good
grades and all but I asked he started to
excel in playing basketball in high in
school from from junior high school up
to high school I actually played on the
junior varsity team and then the varsity
team at Southern High School in
Baltimore Maryland when I was there
prior to that I played and the
neighborhood they had a lead that they
started they called B&B L which is the
Baltimore neighborhood basketball league
where the communities will play against
each other and
the neighbor at the end they will have a
citywide championship that will actually
play at the place called the Baltimore
Civic Center which is now called the
Baltimore arena I was able to hone my
skills and become more experienced and
playing ball and was getting write-ups
in the news American newspaper The
Baltimore Sun paper and regards to being
Player of the Week I actually started
getting recognition for the my ability
to play basketball and in school my
coaches and them were actually treating
me to the point where look Leslie you
have the ability and people are starting
to recognize this and there's a
possibility you might go forward if you
consider playing ball in college and all
which I did I are you getting
scholarship yeah I was looking for
scholarships North North Carolina State
you are seeing Maryland naturally
University of Milan with lefty Jews
they're all down there my honor I met
with him and talked to him before I
asked him before I was going to convict
in it alright and regards to actually
concerning plan at Maryland I had
opportunity to meet with coaches and so
forth for New York when I was living in
New York also in regards to plan boy
I've also played and the Rutgers lead up
there to over then Matt over in
Manhattan up in Harlem and your high
school team was my high school team was
extremely strong we actually went forth
and played at just Dunbar which was a
leading high school in the state of
Maryland they had skip wise they had are
like Gibson who plays Center for dum ba
dum bars coach was a well-known coach
throughout the school lastik our
basketball league his name was sugar
cane these are the individuals that I
play basketball with donuts
I was when I was coming off to come well
before I was wrongfully convicted these
were individuals who actually were
football players in that time did I
plead yeah and then tell me tell me what
happened to you at 17 years old Wow
you're still high school kid ring yeah I
was still a high school kid I worked in
the what they call mule East bakery
witches would say I'm bakery that had
been in business for many years it was
sent it was located near cross street
market and anyone who's for me with
Maryland is familiar with the Inner
Harbor Fells Point those areas are areas
of prominence where people desire to
that
well this bakery that I worked at was
was situated in that community and the
evening after I had basketball practice
I would go to work at the bakery would
stay there and work until later in the
evening and then leave and go to my
grandfather's house who lived on Hanover
Street which was a couple blocks from
the market and all like just by
coincidence I was at home with my mom's
one morning think it was a Sardinian she
asked me to go to the store get a
newspaper something that I've been doing
for years the knowledge was a normal
thing so I went to walked over to a drug
store it's called a Westport pharmacy on
an atlas road which was the only
neighborhood store in the community and
I went in I spoke to doc who was the
owner of the store I spoke with spoke to
clients McCleary we call old mad clients
and mr. Whaley ad was willing oh man
well II they were full time delivery
drivers for the Westport pharmacy that
was in the neighborhood that I lived on
I spoke with them and then I went up
front
I made approaches and I came out of the
store of just a newspaper
yeah the newspaper that's all she wanted
was news because she read the paper and
stuff and yeah and you're basically just
a kid I kid
I was a kid I'm your life revolves
around basketball school mom my life was
about
basketball I didn't have no girlfriends
I wasn't interested in no girlfriend
only girl that I had was that basketball
no gangs nothing but no gangs and all
that stuff during that time if it was it
wasn't in the community that I lived it
was it was none of that it was not the
times that you see now this transpire
it was a whole sin involved my kids used
to go out in the street and play marbles
and skillet and you know a red-hot
butter beans and all those kind of games
and stuff you know our people kids were
kids or adults were adults you know kids
knew what they suppose what was required
I'm done when the likes when I start
getting dark outside and the
streetlights start coming on you know to
be home you know those kind of things
and I came out to drugstore I remember
standing there waiting across the street
coming back towards my home and I heard
this man say you were to level code on
go stat go put your hands against the
wall I know I heard it but I wasn't
really planning on mind because I knew
they couldn't been talking to me I you
know I didn't know that Nobles going on
so I looked and it was an officer or
police officer with his revolver poor
thought he was pointing it and he said
you get up against the wall put your
hands against the wall and I'm looking
at I'm looking cuz I know I brought my
sermon he's not talked to me cuz I ain't
done nothing I don't know what's going
on I appointed myself and he said yeah
you with the base level coat put your
hands against the wall I said what'd I
do
he said get up against the wall and I
walked over put my hands against the
wall and he came up behind me and he
said put your face against the law and
put the gun to the back of my head and
he said you charged you you robbed the
drugs to us and no I did not just come
out the drugstore I suggest us doctor
tell you I didn't ride no just oh he
know me you know who I am and the guy
was two Possible's like I don't care I'm
gonna hit under that and then I heard
him say it's just the guy and the man I
heard a voice I only think because of
him having the gun against my head
my face against the wall I was afraid to
turn my head you know
because I am I just man to shoot me you
know the week prior to this there was an
incident that was there had been
documented and they was talking about
and people was protesting because our
officer asked who supposedly shot at
number teenager and Barton was in some
other community boy and he said you know
you under arrest for robbing the
drugstore and you will be the police
wagon coming to get you and I'm like
well I didn't do nothing so I stopped
you know acts docking him I didn't do
anything and he saw on my head he should
tell you how to tell it to the judge and
all that for all the while I'm saying it
myself god what is going on I came here
to get a newspaper now what so it was
other people standing out there that
lived in that community and the people
was like gloves me what's going on why
did police my son with you and all I
said he said I bribed to just oh he
survived it just these are people in the
community standing around because across
the street from this drugstore was
Holmes was houses right and these people
knew me from the neighborhood and they
was like well well you know you know
what's going on they tried to charge you
the police cha-cha-cha huh this kid live
out here he didn't know him all you got
to do is ask the man asked her owner
he's in the store he didn't do this what
are you talking about so he was like he
was at Mantid he wasn't trying to do
anything but arrest me that particular
day I really you know even as I think
back now and I sit and I remember how
that whole scenario play played out and
the fact that I didn't know I had no
idea what was going on and then him not
one to take me into the store for the
owner of the store to verify that I was
not the person you know just only
inflame things more so a fellow that was
standing there named Horace and Conyers
I don't forget Hassan and I grew up on
Kent Street that's where I lived in our
Kent Street in the West Ward project he
said lastly I'm gonna tell your mom I'm
gonna go Thomas Clardy Poli
arrested you like my mama Nate was
crying all right so he said I'm a good
shot mascara today I bested you and so
forth and I'm like okay but all the
while I'm scared to death because I
don't know what is going on this is not
something that it's not an everyday
thing for me I wasn't I never been
stopped by the police I had never been
accosted and kept any kind of I never
had any kind of interaction with the
police and to be honest with you I was a
child I was 17 years of age but I was a
child in mentality I had no
understanding or what was transpiring I
had no knowledge of what was going to
procedures that was happening you know
only thing I know is that I'm standing
here this man which has gone against my
head and if I move he can kill me that's
all I could take off you know when the
when the police wagon came and he put me
in the police wagon to cart me to the
station I remember when I got there and
they took me out the wagon and officers
sir what's your name and I said Leslie
vas and he said you know how old are you
I said 17 he said 17 he said Sarge we
got a juvenile here he has to be
sequestered from everybody else well I
mean they could put me with other
individuals so he put me in on they
walked me back and put me in this area
where it was just ourselves and I was
saying he put me in the first cell and
he put a tag on this and I was in
juvenile boy and a god I'm gonna go
officer when they call Sarge he said wow
you're a big kid for a 17 year old boy
I stood six for at that time why but
still I just you know as I as I child
abuse we we go back over everything that
happened I just feel like you know it's
it's truly traumatic because I didn't
understand what was going on I had no
idea that I was being so
as I was in a job as a juvenile but I
was being charged as an adult then later
on they came and got me and told me that
I had to see a court commissioner which
they called the initial appearance and
when I went before this man they carted
me in the courtroom I saw my mother and
when I went into court my my could see
her I saw her friend mr. Johnnie sitting
with her and my neighbor Miss Mick which
was a friend like I'm like a aunt to me
right and uh David's telling me just the
whole door I'll be all right and stuff
and then the judge said well we'll
release you into the custody of your
mother because your juvenile you don't
have a progress rocket he said I
remember them saying but I'm telling you
if you go over to that to the pharmacy
would you talk to anybody they work at
the struck pharmacy and it comes back to
the course that's a violation and you
will be reelected and held without bail
all these things is porn to me because I
don't understand what does a bail I
don't you know I don't I don't have no
idea about none of these things you know
they release me and as we was walking
through the car but started telling my
mom's I said look I said I don't know
what these people talking about and
Suzanne don't worry about it I'm gonna
get a lawyer for you you do but the
lawyer you tell you to do that's all I
want you to do don't go over there near
that drugstore Leslie and don't talk to
mr. clients and don't talk there none of
these other people that worked there
because they might like you back up if
you do that's all I could that's all I
remember
lockup if I talk to anybody if I go over
there to that drug store right those
were the things that stuck in my mind
first off I was in a cell by myself
that was I could I could put my spread
my arms out and put my hands on you
sides of balls where I was at with a
little oil toilet and the thing and a
sink
boy you know and I ain't trying to be
there it's not where I want to be
she paid this attorney she up was
referred to this attorney by the name of
Robert Paul Conrad right and when we
first met him
she made it specifically clear to me you
do with this lawyer tell you to do I
don't care what he I'm paying him he's
the lawyer he knows about the law you
don't know anything about it and you do
what'd he say to do so I'm a kid I do
with my mom something to do the first
time that I met him without her the
first thing he said to me was did your
mother send me up or a check or envelope
so I said yes she gave me an envelope to
give to you I give him the envelope and
he starts adding me well we're gonna
have a heron and when we get away I had
to hurt I want you to listen to
everything that I tell you and I'm sad
okay I said what sir I said they said
that I bribed a drug store I knowed I
get on the drug store
I know mr. clients I know mr. Willie
Adams the old man Willie I know old man
Willie a little clients no I said I know
some of the other workers they're
working and stores him and if people can
tell you I didn't write no I didn't rob
that place and he's just looking at me
he said don't worry about that he said
we're gonna take care of this not gonna
be a problem okay so I said all right
I went about doing what I was doing I
was still going to school I remember one
time I got a paper that said I suppose
it went to court from when my mom's
called to talk to your lawyer
he said I'm worried about it that I was
gonna be dismissed boy it's gonna be
postponed and when I could when I asked
you go to court it's going to be going
for
trowel like so I don't know anything
other than what was been said to me that
I'm charged with robbing the drugstore
right
I was arrested February 15th 1975 on
Annapolis Road after walking out of the
drugstore July the 2nd 1975 I appeared
at the then supreme bench for Baltimore
City at 111 North cowboy Street in
Baltimore City for court when I got
there the doors to the courtroom were
asked a lot and people was just standing
around outside waiting for the courtroom
doors to be open so as I was standing
there I see mister clients I see old man
Willie Adams and a senior saw a dude and
they all stand around this white guy
with a yellow Vennela folder right and
they talking again mr. clients look up
and he see me standing over there and he
said to me
lastly what what you going down here and
I'm you know my immediate thought was
these people are like you up if you talk
to this man you understand that's my
first and foremost art I don't want to
say nothing to him so he's like what's
wrong with you Lisa and I bust out
crying and I say to him I said they're
gonna lock me up if I talk to you he
said what are you talking about nothing
I said they charged me with robbing a
drug store inside of me he said wait a
minute
what when that happened I said in
February I'm when I came into the drug
store to make a buy my paper I saw Levi
earlier they arrest me and said I robbed
a dress store he said they'd lock you up
for that I see yeah so mr. Willy is
standing there and he says man what the
hell is going to excuse me he said what
the hell's going on here
and they looking at each other like
you know like like it's something they
know that I'm not familiar I don't know
anything about so he said I said come on
ago with me walk over here so he walks
me over to the white guy with the yellow
folder and he says to him he said y'all
like this kid up for bad disposition who
y'all locked up he said we know this
child this kid comes from our welcome or
community this kid wasn't involved in
this robbery then and we know you know
he said something is not he said this is
not the kid who said that people get
robbed our co-worker were older they
said we know this kid this kid comes in
has been coming to the store since he
was a small little boy you know he said
are you you know got the wrong person
not this boy so the guy I remember the
guy saying at him he said well guess
what we don't we don't need your
testimony we're not gonna use y'all you
dismissed right and mr. Willy said you
know these people could really do some
real [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's what he said
I didn't and I mean I I mean that's
exactly how I said it right then in the
hallway outside of the court must then
they open the doors to the courtroom and
everybody started going in so as I'm
going in mr. Willy said where's your
lawyer yet loves me who is your lawyer
so I said I don't see him right now I
said all day I go he just he just came
up the steps I see he over they talk to
that man y'all was thought to and they
look at each other and then they look
back at me and they said nothing you
know where's your mom's you couldn't
knew that my mom's right my mother was a
single mother does these these people at
this time were delivery drivers who came
into the community to left to deliver
food medication alcohol that it was a
bar in the back of this place and so
they were they were friendly with all
the people in the community you know I'm
standing there and apparently that man
had told mr. Conrad dad
I was talking to the two witnesses and
they had said something to him about it
and he came when he approached me he
approached me like what didn't I tell
you not to talk to nobody about that I
don't care who they are I said well they
they they said they told him that I
didn't do this he said I don't care what
they said I too would you
your mother told you to do what I tell
you to do and that's what you supposed
to do don't talk to nobody there go
there have a seat and I'm saying I'm
trying to figure out why he upset with
me and mad with me because I talk to
these people and these people apparently
know something about what was going on
now when they I'm sitting in I'm sitting
in the courtroom I remember I heard a
movement behind me but my mind is so
messed up about being here I don't
understand what's going on and then I'm
thinking you know why is this lawyer my
lawyer you mad at me you know for
talking with these people who work in
the drugstore you know so he I said it
for him when he come over I said mr.
Conrad
I said they said something about
somebody that was a delivery driver that
was robbed now I said but they charged
me arrived in the drugstore they didn't
send I'm about no delivery driver so he
said you don't know when you never see a
person they're pinky Brown I said nobody
picked me out picked me out for what he
said
lastly the day that she was arrested did
anybody say that you robbed them and I
said no not that I remember I said only
thing I remember was that each girl
officer had the gun to my head
after all I shot a number I heard a
voice the officer said to somebody is
just a man and he said yeah it looks
like him and and then that was it but
there's nothing else said right so I
said I don't know I said what did I
suppose mean he said well so you don't
know that the robbery happened
in November of 1974 and Sherri Hill
so I said Cherry Hill what are you
talking about I was resting on Annapolis
Road right in front of Westport pharmacy
I made me knock out me he said no Leslie
the original crime happened November 2nd
1974 a part-time delivery job before the
Westport farms he was making a delivery
so I said I don't know anything about
none of this I said this the first time
I'm hearing it you know I said you
telling me something I have no idea so I
said if it was on a weekend or some
usually I'm on at my grandfather's house
because want one on Fridays we had
basketball practice I leave here go to
work at Millie's bakery my grandfather
lived right around on corner or I had an
Overstreet and I used to go there and
after bait after work like that the
Burke bakery because it was late in the
evening and didn't know public
transportation runs after a certain
period of time where we lived in so he
said well no I thought you know so I
said well who was this part-time
delivery driver I said because mr.
Clarence I know
Willie Adams I know you understand I
don't know what no other delivery
drivers that worked for the West for
pharmacy I've never known of any so he
said well this man only worked one day a
week on Sardi and he originally works
for the gas electric company but he just
feels that he do part-time work there so
I said who is he
where's yet and he identified me and he
said don't look now lovely but the man
sitting behind you with the rare plant
look like a drummer Jack's shirt on
that's the man and when he said it I
mediator around and look but when I look
back I noticed that the white fellow had
a folder yellow Fenella folder open and
in that folder was my picture when I was
arrested with my Bush and all all over
my head because I didn't have my hair
braided or planet and it was all over my
head in the picture and I was like well
why I said he saw him up
so of me you know though he said Leslie
should just wait here he turned around
and said something to them to fellow
which I've learned was the state
prosecutor and they got up to step to
the side it was talking and stuff then
state prosecutor walked up to the I
think the clerk's desk and sets up to
the clerk and then they said they called
the case of state of Maryland versus
Leslie vast like so mr. clients Willie
Adams asked to speak to my attorney mr.
Khanna and he told them that he couldn't
talk to them because they were listed as
state witnesses and it would be illegal
to charge them I don't know the true
season you know I you know always say I
could go by what I remember of this case
I didn't find out or know anything about
their procedures of criminal law and so
after I was convicted and in prison
well for 20 years sentence at the age of
17 this man the victim they called I
told when they call my case they said
loves me vast the state of my overseas
less Levi's must have asked come up to
the defense table and then the lawyer
started walking up there then the
prosecutor said yarn and we're accident
that the witness be sequestered the
victim be sequestered from the courtroom
right and he gets up from behind me
and walks today walk him to the door and
tell him to go outside of the way
outside then they say go sit anywhere in
the courtroom Leslie because this is
gonna be identification process right
now wasn't that dumb he was just sitting
behind me you understand so why I need
identification process when they showed
him a picture and he sitting right
behind me now you gonna tell me go sit
in the courtroom and then he comes in
and then they asked him well did you see
the man that
man he ain't sick you see the man they
said did you see the third man that was
involved in the robbery of you on
November the 2nd 1974 and I'm all about
like when they send this number November
the 2nd 1974 I'm saying
I was arrested February 15 1975 I'm
accepted no November you know and uh I
mean it's like I was just I got
convicted this crime I've always had
real serious problems about dealing with
how it was done because I felt like
these people they were asked after being
imprisoned for as long as I have as I
was and then finding out the evidence
the stains that actually happened in my
case all of it boils down to the fact
that that the detectives that was in
charge of investigating robbery was
aware that the fellow I was mistaken for
was a informant for them and they
actually allowed me to go to prison to
protect him yeah yeah really you know
just when when it came time for us to
select a trial did get lawyer mr. Conrad
said to me lovely and you suppose when
they ask you what kind of child you have
I want you to say court trial so I said
well my mother said suppose they'll have
a child by jury what's that he said and
she also told you to do what I tell you
to do
he told me to ask for a trial by court
and I said well my mother said was
fooling child by jury
he said no I'm telling you to ask for
trial court so when they asked me I said
okay trial by jury cuz he said that
right and he said that what you want
trial by jury I know child by court so I
said yeah child by court because I was
mixed up
you know and then he said okay and they
had their day
suppose he presented their case and this
Mack I don't understand and started
telling about how three men he went to
make a delivery
three men approached him and robbed him
four hundred and twenty dollars three
men robbed him for $120 and he started
explaining how he left when they robbed
him he got in the car and left and went
to the gas station and called the police
to report it because there were no cell
phones and other stuff at that time and
they met him out there the police about
him out there and he explained to him
what happened and all later on that
afternoon later on that evening his cold
workers mr. Willie Willie Adams and
Connor's McCurry went with him back out
there and they observed three men with
whom he identified as the men who acts
evolved him get into a yellow Volkswagen
with black stripes on it mr. Clarence
know much you to me to the gas station
they used the phone to call the police
and gave them the flumpty cat the car
tag number and the description of the
vehicle and all-points bulletin was put
out the vehicle was stopped and two men
were in the vehicle admitted committing
a robbery
third man wasn't in there wasn't a third
person in there right based on that
information and his in court
identification I was found guilty and I
was detained with a $20,000 bail that
was July 2nd 1975 July 18th they brought
me back to court and they sentence me to
15 years plus five years consecutive
with 215 making a total of 20 years for
armed robbery and I entered into the
Maryland state prison system the
Division of Corrections when I went into
the Division of Corrections I ended up
in the penitentiary was for a
maximum-security facility in the state
of Maryland
longer juvenile no no I was I was I was
an adult they made me an adult
automatically never had a juvenile
waiver heard anything
they mean he just processed me and
that's nothing that I that I went
through when I was confined because I
started I met a guy that was on the
chair above me which was deaf throat and
he introduced me to how to learn the
procedures of doing legal work and I
ended up started studying paralegal I
started probably was the source of doing
my own work on my own case I started
obtaining the documents related to my
case I received our original police
offerings with wart and all that stuff
and uh and the course of me being
confined I actually became known as an
individual who was learned in law right
I worked with a lot of individuals
worked on other individuals cases I
ended up getting cases overturn
sentencing reductions and all that kind
of stuff
right and and 1980 I actually learned
the name of a guy the date that was a
real close friend of those two men that
suppose a bet my co-defendants that I
never met and I asked this lawyer what
not he would get a photograph up to pick
up that man and show it to the victim to
see but not this was the man I was a see
mistaken
this man was the person that I ended up
getting a picture of in 1982 and at the
time I had a petition in federal court
because I had found got tired of dealing
with the state court could I realized
they wasn't gonna give me anything
they weren't gonna adhere to the laws
like they supposed to nowhere in the
world I was supposed to be tried as an
adult and I was a juvenile without a
waiving her that it's not that's not
that's not permissible by law period but
the state of mother kept denying my
petitions so I filed in the federal
court and I got a federal Hearne the
federal court judge stated debt and the
decision he stated that they were if I
presented the state of Maryland with the
last contention about the person I found
out had been I had been wrongfully
imprisoned for if they didn't do
anything and I came back to their Court
they will grant me the relief that I
seek so two years later I get a letter
from the public defender's office saying
that my hard work and perseverance paid
off the photograph of the man that I
gave them their investigator took it to
the victim and he positively identified
the man as being a person who robbed him
and he even had on the same suit that he
bribed him in saying man he had the same
clothes on right then when they
committed the robbery he had on so he
positively identified the state dunk or
curd me back to court they gave me a
court release they granted me a court
release from the 20 years sentence and
when I came home I then continue
advocating for myself I went back and I
got a four on conditional pardon from
the governor for the state of Maryland I
became the first individual who actually
receive a pardon from the governor
unconditionally for the time that I've
been wrongfully convicted I'd then
went forth and filed for compensation up
under our bill a statute that the state
had at that time and they awarded me two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars for
the ten years I spent wrongfully
imprisoned they order I have four
separate orders for expungements of the
criminal records of that case but when I
initially came home the first month that
I was home I spoke with a man by the
name of Al Sanders at wjz-tv channel 13
and Barton Hwan and Mr Sanders
remembered me and remember my story as
being a basketball player he actually
set up an interview for me to play a
fellow that was ranked number I think he
was ranked number one in the United
States as a basketball player and they
had made him play a one-on-one I was at
their time I was 28 I think he might
have been maybe 18 but what's his name
his name was Len Bias boy and they
filmed him and I planned each other and
I beat him two games back to back you
beat him twice twice Vanguard said
what's my number two yeah he was number
two in 86 yeah you know and uh I really
didn't I didn't file a basketball when I
was locked up because it took too much
out of me and made it remind me of all
that I was that I lost that was taken
from me but I would take my my
frustration and anger out on the
basketball court on every team that we
played against and we were beating
Virginia State University Boise State
University Hagerstown Community College
be triple see every institution or every
everybody every team that they brought
in there we was beating them and we was
beating them at will you know this is a
prison team and the prison team but they
wasn't writing that up though you know
name it was their mother Brock has how
how we will beat your six seven yeah
yeah you know and I and I had a attitude
that I don't care who thought she was
you had a god no forget even people 71
they brought him in there in Hagerstown
and we played against of it he was
talking about how many how many points
he was from school I stopped him from
scoring any points early you know get
nothing it's my house you know and that
and and you know after being coming home
and doing the things that I was doing I
felt like you know I was in a process of
trying to put my life back together so
your prime years as a basketball player
18 to 28 we're all spent in prison I my
children I started having children my
first child was born in 1988 you know I
started working and plurid was just and
initially when I applied for jobs that
criminal record would come up every time
even though I had expungement orders a
full unconditional pardon and all that
this criminal record was a bird a bird
and every time I turn around it came up
and I will contact the state of mom the
governor the controller the treasurer
because these were the people that I was
directly involved in in Maryland
regarding my conviction and when I say
that I'm saying I didn't talk to the
assistant I talked to the governor and I
mean I went to these people with
explaining them that this conviction was
was burden me I got a bachelor's degree
in sociology from Towson State
University I was a certified paralegal
and then I also went back to school and
got 450 hours of computer office
experience as well as a computer office
specialist but I couldn't get a job as
well as our correctional officer I
couldn't get a job as well so it's
occurred to God I found I try to get a
job I left Merlyn went back to Brooklyn
in New York try to get a job working
there for a pharmaceutical company and
you had to be bonded because you dealt
with different kind of medications that
was considered controlled dangerous
substances when I applied for the
position they couldn't Barney because
I had a criminal record for armed
robbery even though I got all these
expungement orders and documentation
showing that they was extended and
destroyed it was no longer accessible
and all these kind of things but there
was just things that I was being sent
and the conviction still came up how
long has this remained on your record
I just I just to show you how crazy does
I was in I left Maryland in 2018 and
went to Tampa Florida to work with an
organization called the sunny center
which is a organization run by and are
swarming zone of law and exoneree who
was on death row a lady by the name of
sunny Jacobs her husband actually was
the fellow who was electrocuted and his
body caught on fire when they they did
the death penalty against them
while there I went through things with
them about them about working so I left
and I applied for a position in Oxnard
California for a re-entry program and
that was in 2020 which is this year I
will I drove from Maryland to I Sonora
California I reached there the day after
Thanksgiving I stayed there until
February the 10th when the Live Scan
live scanners are background check came
back and it had the criminal record
ordinaire I contacted the state of
Maryland treasurer's department to
notify them that this has happened again
the last time did it happen they are
paid me an additional $50,000 in 1998
the Attorney General Joe Kern and sent
me a letter telling me today had
expunged they got a separate or for
expungement order and that that record
would never come up ever again I got a
letter from the administrative judge for
the circuit court saying that this
conviction was removed from the record
and we
contacted the FBI director and I was
like wow I got worried about this with
no boy here there's I'm 63 years old and
I'm dealing with the same thing that I
was dealing with back in when I was 17
you know and I mean I lost everything I
lost and you know my vehicle broke down
and on my way from leaving California
when I was told that this conviction
came up again I lost everything I owned
in mind you know everything you know and
it's like I'm starting over at the age
of 62
what was your lowest point in all of
this the lowest point really was just
recently the other day when we was
talking I got a letter I didn't need I
hadn't checked my emails and stuff but I
contacted state of Rhode Island was
trying to make an agreement with them so
they could settle this claim that I have
with them so that I could actually try
to get on home get a place to live get
some of my stuff back and all and I sent
a letter that the agent the state agent
sent me and in the letter he's asked
he's telling me that deconfliction that
I'm talking about this on the record had
nothing to do with my wrongful
imprisonment case and I'm and I'm
looking at it I'm sad at myself man got
nothing I know these people is not here
to start doing this man I didn't I
didn't have no criminal record when I
went to prison the governor gave me a
full unconditional part dating from my
arrest in 1975 which is February 15th
1975 until I was released August of 1986
so anything that happened between that
time of me been incarcerated and suppose
have been destroyed because that's what
expungement means after three years from
the date of the instruments of the order
from the court they supposed to destroy
all roughness to that case this is 2020
what why am i counting wrong or
something I mean not trying to be funny
but honestly and to do you know the
thing
Father's Day I'm living right now temple
rally and and quarters with my nephews
teenager a kid you know I mean I was a
teenager I would know when I was a
teenager you know I was set in my ways I
had my own home I like my own business
going
I worked for the child support in 4000
fiscal order I worked for the state of
mother as an employment placement
specialist I work for the public
defender's office as a paralegal intake
specialist you know all my documentation
showed that my positions I worked there
for all of substance you know and now
you're gonna treat me as though I have
no understanding of what's going on
because you don't want to recognize the
fact that I know what I'm doing as a
paralegal but mind you it still doesn't
change the fact I was wrongfully
imprisoned I wasn't one that committed
the crime so why should I continue to
live and bear the burden of what what
actually a criminal record debt
shouldn't ever have been you know then
you tell people that it's been expunged
so you try to give them impression that
you did what you did to assist me and
you never did all you did was do things
that was hindrance to me you know the
part that hurt the most of all about
this was done in 2004 while working for
the department labor like some
regulation
I had custody of four children I was
working I was part owner to a bail bond
business at that time and was accused of
a crime that I knew nothing about just
like the same thing with that first one
and they held me without bail based on
the same criminal records that the state
in 1998 gave me $50,000 for and I
purchased the transcript of the trial
because I couldn't believe what was
being done and was being done blatantly
with disregard for my rights whatsoever
you know and a subject that that I go
through you know I really go to
I was found not guilty of everything but
my kids was my my food my daughter
Alicia was Alicia was he was 12
Andrea was 11 my son diamante was 7 and
my youngest daughter Alicia was 4 and
they put them in foster care and they
held them in foster care for that whole
period of time while I was confined
waiting to go to trial because I was
accused of being involved in a stabbing
that I had nothing to do with her no
knowledge or I went to trial for three
days the judge did he did they actually
got out of he was retired he had retired
they went and got him out of retirements
name was judge Roger brown in Baltimore
they got him out of out of retirement
for him to handle my case and when the
money the bench conferences judge Brown
says to the state prosecutor this is the
kind of [ __ ] y'all put this man through
he should sue y'all again and I'm saying
this is just this is a this is a
certified copy of the trial transcript
I'm not sayin paper I'm talking about
video you can see us standing that there
and him talking telling the prosecutor
that mr. vaskas sue y'all ass again
that's not he said it and I'm and when I
look at that I think back to it I said
it myself you know they don't realize
the damage that was done when my
children you put my subject' my kids to
this kind of stuff you know do they
understand that right now my daughter
and uh not Alicia but my other daughter
Audrey and I are estranged behind that
because whatever happened during the
time of her being you know in foster
care you don't want to talk about it and
and in a way it's like I feel like I'm
at fault for because of what happened
and then you know I've tried to not
allow myself to stress about it but I
have to because I'm a parent you know I
have grandchildren now
that I focused my life be about you know
this Justin I'm dealing with now is
really hard because it's like I worked
all the years that I did to try to
reintegrate myself back into society as
a positive person I've worked with
different organizations have
documentation and show it you know and
still the state of MA
you won't own up to the truth leave my
stuff you messed up not once but several
times but that that mess up has been
devastating to my life you know and I
feel that they should update they should
do what they supposed to tell where
their moments for you just felt like
this was a dream yeah really really a
lot of times I thought I couldn't
believe that this was the one more and
that it's still wrong did he ever catch
the person that did the robbery yeah the
one that one no daily dare to catch him
they already knew who he was you know
they knew who is he it was nothing that
they could do to him because what
happened is the statute of limitation
was 10 years the anytime only time that
a person can be charged with anything as
if it was a charge Devils carried a life
sentence if it was a rape or murder
right and they caught they carried life
sentences so there's no statute of
limitation or now but I tried I might
just well you know I would like to ask
governor Hogan and Merlyn what is the
statute of limitation when you do the
things that you do to deprive your
constituents of the freedom of their
life you know their livelihood and your
and when the evidence is presented to
you and study you're acknowledging that
something has been wrong and done wrong
admitted and corrected or do whatever
you can to correct it but Dennis that's
not how they look at this I feel like
that you know people aren't understand
the grabs you the things that going on
behind us it's a lot you know I don't
had that but time to stop and think
that's why it's still on my throne I try
to stay on the book I try to do
everything I can to not allow me to sit
there every flat over the
that have been going on things I haven't
done and the things that that I've been
deprived of having the opportunity to
network with my children with my
grandkids and stuff like that because of
the circumstances that I've been dealing
with and the telling part is that I
started out at 17 and I'm 62
yeah you know Leslie well thank you so
much for sharing your story
Thank You MA to the credible story thank
you mom
you